we have some new information in the fire  that left hundreds of thousands of  dollars in  damages it's right near downtown las  vegas it happened near las vegas  boulevard and oaky  yesterday we brought it to you live fire  officials say that a body was found  inside the vacant wedding chapel  initial reports were that no one was  inside however when firefighters  ultimately returned to the scene this  morning they did find that body inside  three agencies come together and go in  at the same time and work together to  determine  what caused that fire and why a person  died in it  las vegas fire and rescue say the fire  was well advanced when responders  arrived on scene and they couldn't get  inside the building  due to the fear of a possible collapse